[Music]
hey how's it going bros my name is
PewDiePie ooh
today we're playing three free games
even though kids doesn't want to play
games anymore what a massive [ __ ] [ __ ]
nope stop stop go away you know what
fine I'll play games if that's what you
want Who am I not to cater to my fanbase
listen I got to get those views up
somehow oh boy have I collected some of
the finest games from the north s West
to the south at least the first game the
first game it's called calm down
Stalin it's a game about killing
yourself which I think seems pretty
appropriate hey hey Stalin here what can
I do for you please hand I'm going to
kill myself I swear I will do it how do
I switch hands okay you switch hand by
clicking right my dad and I have [ __ ]
the clothes your hand is too the button
the higher is the effect hey listen up
[ __ ] do you think I'm smiling no
my face do not change I am always the
space don't think I won't press the
button because I will press the button
it says hot now I will smoke ah that
feels good
I've become German now this is so bad
it's so and maybe I'm just bad hey you
think I will place this [ __ ] but you
see me do you think I won't [ __ ]
press this button hail Hydra
I got Obama on the on the cell right
here
my Russian accent is [ __ ] horrific
you think I will [ __ ] call oh I
almost dropped on the button that's how
much [ __ ] business I mean what the
[ __ ] happened there go back for you just
say that you're fine and you're not
really fine basically [ __ ] hey come
back in your [ __ ] phone who is it no
I I think I am the better worse best
let's player of this game in the entire
universe and thank you very much I think
it's time to move on to the next game
aren't you excited we get to play more
than one game how about that
now this game I really really really
really want to play a lot like genuinely
I would play this on my spare time
probably would March yeah probably
that's a lie but still I really I'm
really excited
I'm really excited
[Music]
I will I will no I will I'm really I'm
really I'm really I really am really
excited
okay here we go alien invasion oh don't
tell me we missed it
Oh sign me it if that's the Risso [ __ ]
oh my bad ass babes
press Start oh my god there's so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's not a dragon coming
out of her tits oh my [ __ ] god we
select the character I guess we go with
the naked one oh she's twerking
fantastic trapped in green slime and
experimented on for months here we are
wow what a great game oh boy her name is
aja now that that's that's ain't nothing
wrong with it oh [ __ ] they got my
sisters oh all the hot babes are in this
game oh this is just the greatest game I
have ever played Wow look how many hot
babes this game hands
oh it's mister oh I love mystic she's so
hot take this alien scum oh [ __ ] it's
right in my [ __ ] face it's got claws
and [ __ ] no no no no best [ __ ] use of
green screen I have ever seen Oh
I don't think I wasn't ready for that my
special move I'm really having a good
time over here this is really fun I'm
really really enjoying myself I think
it's a good game it's got good graphics
I looks up to standard with any Call of
Duty game I mean really what can you
complain about in a game like this I
just really think it's a good game I
don't know does it have ticks in the
background yes it does but that doesn't
mean it's not a good game of any we
should taken less seriously if anything
it just makes it better because you just
had tits to things and it just it just
get just get just get sad it just shoot
out of my [ __ ] I think that's about
enough of that game thank you so much
for all the hard work that went into
that I really really like games
okay the last game make America great
again okay oh my god I'm so cute look at
this [ __ ]
Oh terrorists
[Music]
[ __ ] one [ __ ] bullet hits me and I'm
dead you know
Trump really gets down to business and
you got to respect that
oh you got to jump over the bullets seed
see I didn't know that and if I defeat
that
it's an if touching barbed wire with
your [ __ ] feet kills and maybe you
don't deserve to be President
hi ever again I can't even jump that far
damn barbed wire come on we can do this
come on come on
Trump come on Trump no [ __ ] nope oh
that's right barbed wire
you can't stop freedom oh [ __ ] this can
be heard oh [ __ ]
[Music]
are you serious are you [ __ ] kidding
me how the [ __ ] am I gonna do that
I'm gonna gonna fit - you have not fit -
oh my god I'm gonna hate oh why do I
care why do I care this is stupid I
don't care [ __ ] that game you tell them
alright here we go come on vote for
Trump does Hillary is gay Oh oh hey I
bet you thought the video was over ten
minutes no but for real
I watched her the video and it doesn't
have a single good game in it
so I thought hey let's let's put in a
good game that you bros can play as well
at home and not because I want this
video to be ten minutes long look it
maybe both maybe both is that so [ __ ]
bad you're gonna see a lot of youtubers
play this game all right they're gonna
make a whole episode of it drag that
[ __ ] out nothing wrong with that I can
respect that if you go to dam dot dog
this is really funny website that lets
you guess what the wikiHow is compared
to the image now if you don't know what
vici how is it's basically a website
that will explain [ __ ] anything yeah
if I search a wiki how PewDiePie how to
build a [ __ ] channel how to be a
fangirl alright and they always have
these [ __ ] pictures we're gonna guess
together what it is how to get your
nipples pierced
now that's probably not it I'm gonna
have to go with yes that's right
hey this section pretty fun I should
probably make a full version of
different if that Scooby Doo how to get
over a crush on your best friend how to
buy fire hocks how to be interesting
okay
it seems like I have a natural talent
for this how to tell a girl you like her
smoking tricks for sure yeah yeah yeah I
know that one that's called the Chinese
dragon look at that fart quietly hey
what's in the title of this wikiHow
article how to get famous wall young
famous okay it seems like I'm I am
really good at this how to act like
sonic venture this is only fun because
of the things okay husband that you love
him that's it yeah how to stop staring
at a girl's boob whoa that must be a hey
what is the title of this week eHow
article uh you know what actually I
really enjoyed this one maybe I'll make
a full episode maybe I'll play it
together with someone but yeah that's it
for me for now I hope you enjoyed for
three games with parents let me know
which one you like the most leave a like
if you enjoyed watching and as always
stay awesome